i'm so excited i'm always appreciative
of this man appearing on this show he's
made many appearances i'm a big fan the
many saints of newark is something that
i've been looking forward to for a very
long time it is the prequel the much
anticipated prequel to david chase's
the sopranos and it's david chase's baby
and part of the cast is in fact one of
the
the best in the business and we all know
him from certainly his role in
goodfellas the many saints of newark
star ray liotta here on the rich eisen
show how are you bud
good how are you richa i swear that
wasn't cool
that was
your time i know that was one of i i i
still passed this the goodfellas poster
that's hanging in in my green room from
your appearance years ago here on this
show it's it's the greatest man i mean
and you know
the fact that you resigned it because
you said that the signature on it was
fake still breaks my heart but it's
still great that you've resigned it at
least right you know i'm glad that it's
still there but is it still all uh
sharded up yes
it is sharded up because you took an axe
to it and taking an axe to it to try and
break it open to re-sign it
you actually hit your head the
photograph of your head on the movie
poster it looks like you were actually
gunning for yourself right i'll be
honest well it served me right it's the
best but it really was that wasn't mine
so you really have a unique poster thank
you very much uh so let's talk about the
many saints of newark um what can you
tell us
about this i'm sure it's very secretive
i'm sure david chase is keeping
everything under wraps but what can you
tell everyone who's been waiting for
something like this for some time
right
what i can say is
and i because i believe it the series
the eight or nine years of night of ten
however long i never really watched it i
would see the show every now and then
then like years after they were after
david for a while to write a movie about
it
he didn't know like a way in and he
figured something out and the movie
itself is if you've never seen a stitch
of of uh
the sopranos it has nothing to do with
with the many saints of north that
they're both standalone
pictures you don't have to know the
characters and then the few times that
there are characters
being played by the actors that later be
you know was in the series
you could see like the the beginning of
their journey but also too it does stand
alone
you don't have to have like been a
sopranos fan to to enjoy it so uh but it
it still has i imagine because it's
david chase and that the characters and
it's uh new it's new jersey it does have
the same feel to it it's the same
sort of spirit oh it was oh yeah it's
it's raw
it it's it's as raw as the mafia movie
could be
there's there's people not doing very
well and getting sick and
and other things it's it's definitely
wrong
i can't wait for this what was it like
what i think is great is michael
gandolfini i was about to say that what
was it like to be on the set with
james's son who's playing the younger
version of his character
from the sopranos
i only knew james
uh
just
you know here and there
uh but michael i never had a day
that he worked the same day that i
worked and there was a little overlap i
wasn't about to tell him like tell me
what it's like to play yeah your your
parent your father who passed away that
you're the one who found them i mean
when you really really think about what
that is that that's that's some heavy
stuff
and he did it and he's cool and he's a
good actor on his on his own
a kudos for as far as i'm concerned for
him he was great
everybody is in this movie but he did
that in particular wasn't it had to be
not the easiest part to play who do you
play in this ray your character is aldo
hollywood dick multicenter would
walk us through who that is and how you
played him in this well okay so
my my son
who ends up doing bad things to me
uh
wants wants wants to have a kid one
meets the other guy
in prison and talks
and talks to him
and uh
in this way it was
what was the name of the character that
that michael imperially played this
christopher
yeah christopher yeah christopher
right he would have i would have been
his grandfather okay
my son would have been his father
but we become
scarce after a little bit
and and he moves on and
starts the journey of where it did i
just think the way david did it was so
smart he didn't hit it over it over
people's heads he did it the way that he
felt was the best way to tell it without
you know
going overboard so
like like anything it's really about the
script
really especially in this business
if yeah
short ray liotta here on the rich eyes
and [ __ ] giants won by two last night
no you must have turned that one off
right before the end of the the field
right before the end of the game no
washington won on a field goal uh on
thursday night football yeah yeah yeah
yeah but they were playing the giants
that they were playing the giant the
giants your team ray are they your team
no
no when i tell you what was really
interesting since we're talking sports
all right i'm changing the whole thing
let's go was the game at the field of
dreams field
so you did see that though did you watch
that course i did
i know because the last time you were on
the show you had mentioned you had never
seen the field of dreams you'd never
seen the film yeah right so what did you
think of that what what did you think of
the game
being at the field of dreams i watched i
watched bits and pieces of it i didn't
realize that they cut down more corn and
put a professional
a professional field there because i
knew what we played on you know even i
was hitting them into the corn so i know
these guys would have uh
that i didn't realize they built such a
big big thing i thought it was
such a cool sporting good thing and the
way they did it it really gave a
reverence to
you know
sports and it looked beautiful it looked
beautiful it looked beautiful beautiful
i mean was it did it look that i mean
and the the night sky was all sorts of
colors it was that
i i thought sometimes that that might
have been just a movie trick but that's
literally the way it was when you shot
it right
[Music]
you totally because just think about it
it's nothing but corn so there's no
street lamps or or any kind of lighting
to show the billboards or you know cars
going by it's just dark because it's
just out there and you know
acres and acres and acres of of of corn
i got rayleigh odor i was really blown
out me too and they're gonna make
they're gonna have more games there uh
next year i personally think they should
have every major league team show up
there everybody should get every fan
base should make a pilgrimage and i
should introduce every one of them
why not you shouldn't you
you should come out of the field exactly
you should come out of the field with
the yankees the next time
you know i i was thinking about that
except the crazy thing is they're
honoring the field of dreams but the
white sox and and julie joe in
particular was banned from the game for
gambling
so if you really look about what the
movie says or what it's about it's more
than like a son playing a catch with the
with their dad right
that's my
i think it was my favorite line of
viewers in the movie is that you that
they all left you all left out ty cobb
because he was just he was mean you know
like nobody likes ty cobb yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's a funny line in that
movie um i i gotta i want to ask you a
couple of things about uh goodfellas ray
i just want to go down this wormhole
with you if you don't mind uh is it true
that the fame scene of pesci saying how
am i clown do i muse you he was
ad-libbing it and at one point you
literally thought that he was serious
that everybody thought that he was
really being serious is that a true
story or no
there's a true story that happened to
joe
we had the luxury of having two weeks of
rehearsal
mee joe bob lorraine and and martin
scorsese
uh
and joe just he's a great storyteller
and he was just telling a story that how
he was in queens one day and you know he
said something to uh a guy like
you know what we're thinking and
the guy just turned on joe in a dime it
just
so joe was kind of like back in austin
no no i'm just saying that
so so what happened is he told that
story and marty said you know what i
like that and i know good place to put
it uh let's work this out
so we just started kind of uh with that
kind of we were ad-libbing back and
forth but then when when
they when they thought that that when
marty thought the scene was shaped to
where
it would sound good and then you know
like it was part of the the brain script
that that they wrote
uh
they they added it in
and what happened was that all right so
they're doing all those extras there's
like a hundred extras we're going
through the kitchen we got a guy picking
up a table moving it right then you boom
all of a sudden we're in the center of
this thing
she says what do you do and i said the
construction then it goes up to henny
youngman and after all that he forgot
his line he thought he forgot his own
joke are you serious
for real yeah
so that one huge long shot that every
you know he did so what happened to do
it again
we had to do it again because but the
whole thing was a was one shot
it was like this you know steady cam and
right that wasn't there's no cutaways
that it was it was that was not us when
we sat down and then to henny
were the joke
you know you know he did it the second
time the third time everything was fine
but i just thought well here's a little
fun fact for you
so your line was ad-libbed about you
know i'm just joking with you like
seriously like the the funny how scene
you're oh yeah that that
that was all oh holy [ __ ] because i know
that tommy's a nut job and you know
kills people at the drop of a hat
uh i don't even know if that's an
expression but i like no that's it
that's not a bad one right that's not a
bad one i just dropped the hat huh i
like it
i'm getting jockey what's your favorite
what's your favorite scene from
goodfellas which one are you the most
proud of
from that film that i've seen 90 million
times literally it's maybe the movie
i've seen more than any other movie in
my entire life is good fellas
so which one would that be
for you it's too edgy and
i i like you and i feel like we're just
talking alone even though there's
probably millions of people listening
my mother passed away in the middle of
shooting good fellas
cancer
so there was a scene
that we did to finish up the day
and then we were off on a friday
saturday sunday was a burial and people
coming over to to the house of mourn and
the most classy thing
that that was done
was a lot of the teamsters and pesci
came to my house in new jersey to pay
respects to my mom i almost get choked
up now
and so it's not so much a favorite scene
but when i come back the first thing is
me
is the rain is karen coming at me
yelling who do you think you are thank
frankie bally you can't just make a date
and not show up and blah blah blah right
so it's not that it's a favorite scene
to do
but it's you know
it's the most
emotionally packed
thing in in the movie for me just based
on that light fun little airy story that
i just told you no no that disrupts your
rating no no no
not at all right no not at all it's it's
a fascinating i had no idea
that that was that now that scene will
be different for me you know from now on
um what about the scene with scorsese's
actual mother
you know uh that was great when i'm in
that way when the dinner what's the
guy's name
yeah you know billy bats and yeah billy
batts billy batches in the trunk right
cause they beat him up at my bar right
uh
that was really fun because one that
really was her sauce and that sauce was
really brewing for a couple days like
like an old school italian woman or man
would do
so it was like no one was to touch it
every now and then she'd go in and she'd
stir it
uh
it it was it was just and then they do
not that of that was a lot of uh improv
that bob and joe did and one of the best
one is when joe says look at this what
does going this way one dog's going that
way and this guy's saying what do you
want from me it was just
joe just pulled that out of the air
it cracks me up it was a really good one
for that painting like
a fun guy
oh my god that's so he sees that
painting and and that was just his
ad-lib how about him saying to take the
knife
did was that ad lib too he took the
knife for later on yeah because we got
no that was because we got to get the uh
what it called the paul there's at the
top
it was just all matter of fact like all
right well let's eat before we bury the
guy i mean i'm hungry
[Laughter]
i love that's her real sauce that she
was really cooking for the scene that is
amazing yeah yeah that is my favorite
thing she's like you know are you guys
hungry you want something to eat i'll
just whip something up and it looked
like a 19 course meal the smash cut
right to a night like a full table of
food was in the movie too right
his dad
was the guy
who said that's that right joe called
noah bob calls to see what happened with
with thomas yeah with pesci
uh he gets a call and and
you know yeah
it's uh there's no good
he didn't make it he's gone what do you
mean he didn't make it he he didn't make
it
and that that was uh morty's dad
yeah in in actuality yeah the pay phone
outside the diner to find out the bad
news oh my god i'm telling you all this
stuff because i feel like i owe you for
the broken fugazi
it's not your fault somebody's you know
falsifying your autograph on something i
spent four figures on no big deal don't
worry about it be told one day i saw
something and i was really tired and
someone came up it could have really
been mine
it hits me in their head because it was
such a it was like it was funny but it
was like
i felt bad
[Laughter]
i didn't feel that bad but i felt bad
ray you're the best man thanks for the
time i cannot
wait to see
this filmed thank you
appreciate it cool let's do this again
you got it so much more to talk about
even the next time ray liotta here on
the rich eisen show
mercedes-benz vans phone line
the many saints of newark available in
theaters and on hbo max october 1. ray
leota what a legend hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here